ce responsable politique indien a bu
l'eau d'une rivière sacrée pour prouver
qu'elles n'étaient pas polluer mais il a
finalement dû être hospitalisé voici ce
qu'il s'est passé tout a commencé le 17
juillet 2022 bagman ministre en chef du
pendjab organise une opération de
communication sur les rives du kali been
une rivière sacrée en inde l'objectif
trouver que l'eau n'est pas pollué mais
deux jours plus tard le ministre en chef
a été admis à l'hôpital en urgence
officiellement pour des douleurs
intenses à estomac selon le média the
indian express cette hospitalisation
étaient bien liées à la consommation
d'eau de la rivière polluée le
responsable politique est depuis
retourné au travail en bonne santé le
cas libyen illustrent bien les problèmes
de pollution de l'eau en main dans cette
rivière de 165 km est à la fois polluée
par les déchets industriels mais aussi
par les égouts dizaines de villages qui
se déverse en l'an 2000 un militant
écologiste lancé une opération de
nettoyage de grande envergure avec
l'installation de stations d'épuration
sensibilisation des habitants et ses 22
ans après l'eau est certes moins pollué
mais de nombreux poissons ils meurent
encore à cause de la pollution